what it's going on YouTube and welcome
to another episode of pocket I'm David
this week's episode about the heart we
have Johnson like I said in this week's
episode we have a very special guest
Joseph Vincent he's gonna use this you
know some [ __ ] so today we're gonna get
to know each other bits a little bit
more on the personal scale what he likes
to do and know now how and if you go
back that's a question to ask
[Music]
I wanna do the you have to is your job
it's my job let me tell you something I
don't want to do why don't you like him
first of all the first time I met him
you only said to me this fool had the
audacity said hey David I like your work
and you're doing a great job
Kasane I'm insane I'm insane that's why
your daddy left you do exactly
hey seriously this man long time no see
so how's the music business going for
you yeah oh it's going great
I just yeah so you better than people's
what you saying no I didn't say yeah I
know that's what I heard
no you better people I didn't say that
what's your name Joe Jesus Vincent yeah
but you holier than thou I see you do
the question there unless it comes to
the earth you wanna know would you
you don't read books do you well how'd
you burn down a library much the baby in
the mouth is that true hey I was with
you I don't like you I actually hate you
did you see the way he was talking to me
yeah yeah are you talking about what am
I talking about I clearly was
disrespectful and then he came back with
all that respect you come say sarcasm
just go back there and do your job do my
job do much you went a lot to add to for
somebody's long the camera yeah let me
tell you something this is my job oh
okay we
I think you guys should go to my house
you might as well just change your name
of Jesus Vincent did you did you rig the
special you don't like babies do you
does sunshine make you angry
do you like touching yourself to your
own pictures I don't like you you remind
me of Hitler every second how many baby
elephant somewhere well that it for this
week's episode of heart-to-heart with
David so and I'll catch you all on the
episode and Joseph Vincent if I ever see
you on the streets I'm a punching your
testicles like speed Ben except
sometimes oh you never tweet me bad
[Music]